[Applause]
[Music]
Brazil is the country of the future but
it seems like we've been hearing that
for a long time lately though we've
heard a lot about the country's
corruption scandals the economic crisis
is going through all the street violence
in cities like Rio de Janeiro but there
is something even more important about
this country something that doesn't
appear very much in the media Brazil is
the most expensive country in all of
South America yep you heard that right
if you go shopping in a city like Sao
Paulo or Rio de Janeiro you'd better be
ready to clean out your wallet because
it will be as expensive as New York or
London
the Brazilians even have a name for this
they call it custo Brazil this is the
special charge you have to pay for
living in the country of Samba so let's
look at an example the Big Mac burger
that you buy from McDonald's if you've
been subscribed to visual politic for a
long time you already know that the
economists use something called the Big
Mac index to measure the cost of living
in a country for example in Switzerland
one of the wealthiest countries in the
world the Big Mac costs a whopping six
point seven five dollars then we have
Peru a poorer country where the burger
only costs three dollars and 23 cents
fair enough right well in Brazil the Big
Mac costs five dollars and ten cents
it's more expensive than in Denmark the
UK or Canada according to the expat
estanque on websites our power is the
most expensive city in South America
with prices as high as Houston Texas
Berlin or Germany
and now you might wonder given the high
cost of living how high a Brazilian
salaries of a wealthier save and
Colombians or Chileans well absolutely
not the average wage in Brazil is less
than $600 a month
Argentinians and Chileans are actually
better off in this regard
so the real question here is why is
Brazil so expensive what are the reasons
why a middle-income country has the
prices of a wealthy one well today we
are going to answer this question and
believe me this also partly explains the
Brazilian crisis too so let's dive in an
isolated economy many of you might think
of Brazil as a country opens a free
trade right well at the end of the day
many foreign companies like MasterCard
or Barclays have a strong presence in
this country
[Music]
nonetheless Brazil has the highest
tariffs in South America so what does
this mean well imagine we have a
cellphone manufacturer in America and
they wanted to sell on the Brazilian
market since our product is made abroad
we must sell it with a special tax that
could reach up to 35% of its market
price as you can imagine this type of
policy has a pretty big impact on
everyday life
[Music]
Nintendo exits Brazilian market due to
high tariffs yes you heard that right
during those years Brazilians who wanted
to buy a Wii or a Nintendo DS had to
travel to Uruguay in order to find one
interestingly this was a great advantage
for Nintendo's biggest rivals especially
Microsoft and the Xbox and you know why
while Microsoft has a factory in Brazil
where the Xbox one is made this means
they don't have to import it and
therefore it doesn't have those high
tariffs
[Music]
and yes I know you're thinking high
tariffs are cool because they force
companies to build factories in your
country and employ your citizens right
well think twice there when Microsoft
opens their Brazilian Factory they still
need to import all the machines and
materials needed to manufacture that
Xbox one
this can be plastic semiconductors
robots many of these things aren't made
somewhere else
and if they are made somewhere else
they still have these special tariffs
and you can guess who pays for these
extra costs of course it's the consumer
this explains why so many products
manufactured in Brazil are so expensive
what an example take the Volkswagen Golf
in Mexico City this car costs around
fifteen thousand US dollars
[Music]
in Sao Paulo it cost 25 thousand US
dollars all of this despite the fact
that this specific model of automobile
is manufactured in Sao Paulo but wait a
minute because this is not the only
thing that explains this custo Brazil or
the Brazilians used to refer to this
incredibly high cost of living just a
cool store let's imagine someone doing
soy agriculture in the state of power in
the north of this country if he wants to
send his soy to Sal Paulo he must carry
it on trucks through the highway be are
163 this highway has over a thousand
kilometres and a hundred of its are not
even paved a simple rainy day is enough
to keep those trucks stuck in the mud
and this is just one example
in fact Brazil has some of the worst
infrastructure in the world
even India has better roads so to make a
comparison anytime an American farmer
sells $100 in soy he has to spend nine
dollars on transportation the same
farmer in Brazil they'd have to pay $25
since they have no good roads Brazilians
have to invest in expensive trucks that
break down quickly and make the cost
even more expensive and of course all of
this means higher and higher prices for
Brazilian customers but now you might be
wondering well why is the Brazilian
government so reluctant to pay for
infrastructure at the end of the day
Brazil has state-of-the-art engineering
companies companies like the Auto bracht
group
[Music]
if you happen to be someone watching
from a South American country while this
name probably rings a bell few other act
was the biggest engineering and
construction company in the region and I
do say was here because they had the
biggest corruption scandal in the
history of the continent and naturally
with that the future of the firm is
looking pretty dim but this story does
explain well why Brazil has such poor
infrastructure because at the end of the
day part of the money goes towards
bribes and corruption but not only that
when the Brazilian government's wanted
to modernize their country well what did
they do well they decided to host the
Olympic Games and the FIFA World Cup
so today Brazilian cities can
congratulate themselves for having the
most beautiful sports arenas with
high-end technology and luxurious
decoration today taking a walk in the
center of south power it feels like
being in a sci-fi movie but outside of
this metropolis the railroads are
abandoned the highways are unpaved and
several neighborhoods don't have a
single bus line that connects them with
the city centre
missiles woeful infrastructure cost the
economy as much as 48 billion US dollars
per year now of course this effects the
prices for Brazilian consumers but also
for worldwide consumers who want to buy
Brazilian goods but that is something
we're actually going to address in a
future video because now the question
really becomes how can someone who makes
six hundred bucks a month spend twenty
five bucks on Pizza at an average
restaurant in South Paulo well I am
going to tell you how render holics for
decades Brazil had some of the highest
inflation in the world during the 1980s
and 90s they had more than 6-thousand
percent inflation this means if you had
a beer at a Rio de Janeiro bar in 1980
you would pay 100 crucero the createrra
was the Brazilian currency back then one
year later that same beer would cost six
hundred thousand cruzeiro's as you can
imagine hyperinflation created unique
consumer behaviour
behavior that was quite different from
the rest of the world in order to
survive Brazilian ships got used to
selling with installments and this is
still a thing today if you go to any
Brazilian shop you can see that next to
the prices says something like 10 X 12 X
or 20 X this number means that you can
pay for this product on 10 12 or 20
installments in other words the question
many Brazilians ask themselves is not
whether this TV or this suit is more or
less expensive but if they can pay for
it during the next two years and as you
can imagine when you buy something in
installments it is far more expensive
[Applause]
[Music]
the example on the screen we're showing
you a smartphone on a brazilian
ecommerce website if you bought it once
it costs 632 wrists which is equivalent
to two hundred and two dollars at the
moment we made this video nonetheless if
you buy with installments it costs two
hundred and seventeen US dollars which
is a seven percent increase so as you
can imagine your average Brazilian is in
debt all the time nearly sixty percent
of Brazilians in installment debt but
wait just a minute because this is not
the worst of it in the last year
something has happened in Brazil that
has turned custo Brazil into a real
nightmare renege card held at the
beginning of the 2000s Brazil was the
perfect market for foreign banks big
financial firms like Santander or Credit
Suisse started investing in the country
and don't forget we're talking about a
200 million person country that was on
the rise here where prices were high and
people are used to paying for things in
installments
in other words Brazil was a paradise for
selling credit cards since 2005 brazil's
credit card market has grown at a 20%
plus rate annually
by the year 2012 Brazilians had an
average of two credit cards per person
and they really knew how to use them
Brazil was the country with the most
credit payments across all of South
America nonetheless at happiness it
didn't last very long
resilient consumer default and credit
cards has reached 27 percent in April
2012 in the very same year 2012 the
alarm started to sound in all those
Brazilian banks the country was in the
middle of a crisis with rising
unemployment and declining salaries and
that made it hard for Brazilians to pay
back their debts so what happens when a
bank is afraid of getting into falters
well they raise the interest rates
residents have to pay four hundred and
fourteen percent interest on their
credit cards so imagine you use your
credit card to buy a TV screen that
costs you a thousand US dollars and you
pay for it in 12 installments well at
the end of the day counting the interest
rate of the credit card the TV costs
around five thousand US dollars pretty
impressive isn't it and don't forget
that the average wage in Brazil is less
than $600 a month
in other words no matter the
anti-poverty measures taken by the
government most Brazilians are
struggling to survive and west of all
since they can't save money losing a job
can be a real tragedy for many homeless
population in Rio de Janeiro increases a
hundred fifty percent in three years
so here is the question now can Brazil
get over this situation who could
possibly reform this country well we'd
love to know what you think so please
leave your answer in the comments
section below also do not forget to
check out our friends at the reconsider
Media podcast they provided the vocals
in this episode that were not mine also
I've got a new channel it's called
biographic so we do biographies of
notable people from history as well as
the present-day you can find a link to
that in the description below and also
don't forget that here at visual politic
we publish brand new videos every week
so please do subscribe and you will not
miss a post or so if you like this video
give us a thumbs up and as always I'll
see you next time and if you want to
learn more about politics and here even
more of my lovely voice you can join us
at reconsider media we have a podcast at
reconsider mediacom slash podcast see
you there
[Music]